it works okay how's everybody doing so
talk about right now and we're entering
the graveyard shift here right so I'm
going to try and be I hope tight leave
some time for questions and still get
you all to part of your home on time so
as I'm sure you all know for a long time
the dominant paradigm in public health
and health education has been that it's
what individuals do or don't do that
influences their health food we'd
whether we smoke or don't smoke drink or
don't drink who we have sex with how we
drive and so on and I think many of us
are frustrated with that paradigm and
see its limitations both in the
efficiency of interventions that require
changing one individual at a time and
the dangers of victim-blaming of saying
that individuals are responsible only
for their health status or for the
disparities they experience with other
groups and so for the last few years
with my colleagues we've been working to
develop an alternative paradigm one that
looks at the behavior of corporations
and how does that influence health and
so that's what I'd like to talk about
with you this afternoon and my you know
it takes it takes a village to create a
field my partners in this study are in a
variety of disciplines and the work is
very much informed by the contributions
of Epidemiology economic sociology
anthropology as well as other
disciplines and the talk this afternoon
comes out of work I've done over the
last few years looking at six industries
alcohol tobacco food food and beverages
pharmaceuticals firearm and automobile
six industries that are central to the
US and global economy and that have a
major influence on morbidity and
mortality not only in the United States
but in around the world and we're also
particularly interested in understanding
weather changing corporate practices
might be a new avenue to reducing
disparities and
l Thorian equities in hell so here the
five main points I'm going to try and
develop first that what companies do as
a big influence on health and disease
second that the influence of
corporations is growing third that what
companies do particularly the industries
that I mentioned has either maintains
creates or exacerbates inequities in
health that's the bad news the good news
is that we as public health
professionals researchers advocates can
do something to change this and I'll
talk briefly and refer you to our
project website for case histories of
groups that have been successful in
modifying corporate practices and
finally that I think underlying all this
is what as a society do we want from our
government and what do we want to leave
to the free market system and I think
that question of the appropriate balance
between the public sector government and
markets it's it's a critical implicit
question in the two thousand eight
election and it's also a critical
question facing our society and facing
us as health researchers and health
professionals so you know one of the
very clear examples of corporate
practices that our colleague marion
Nestle has written about is the portion
size and super sizing portions you know
when I was a kid and he went to the
movies you got maybe 8 or 12 ounces of
soda now you get 32 or 40 and this
little girl is on a track to like so
many other young children of becoming
overweight and then obese and the
lifetime burden of that is associated
with so I'm going to talk about what
we've come to call corporate practice
it's what businesses do to enhance their
objectives of maximizing profit gaining
market share shifting costs to other
external forces and so on it's for the
most part perfectly legal it's what
corporations are mandated to do and the
question is
what's its impact on health and what can
we do about that and we'll talk about
from our work in the field we've
identified for corporate practices and
I'm going to briefly describe each and
then talk about the pathways by which
they contribute to hell so product
design refers to business the decisions
of businesses make about the
characteristics of a particular product
and where to invest money and sports
utility vehicles are a good example
between 1980 and 2000 market share for
SUVs increase doubled from twenty
percent to forty percent what does this
have to do with health well SUVs are
more likely to rollover injuring the
people inside crushing the people who
they hit they are more likely to be
involved in accidents they are more
polluting contributing to air pollution
also to global warming it's not that
people were in the streets demonstrating
we want SUVs between 1980 and 1990 but
rather the US auto industry decided
because profits are much higher on SUVs
than regular sedans that they would
increase production of these vehicles
and they spend nine billion dollars
between 1990 and 1999 advertising SUVs
making people believe that they could be
the outdoors person they always wanted
to be the man they always want it to be
even the safe driver that they wanted to
be by driving an SUV the exactly the
reality is studies show that most people
only use their SUV for off-road driving
you know when they go over the curve of
their driveway coming home late at night
we got a few too many dreams but that
notion that image that we if we wanted
to we could drive up the mountain if we
wanted to you know we could drive
through that River as appeal to people
trans fat added to foods or another
example by the early 1990s forty percent
of the products in the u.s. supermarket
had trans fat no no nutritional value
not essential to any food but preserved
shelf life and therefore increases
flexibility and profitability the second
corporate practice is marketing this
includes advertising point of production
promotions etc uptown cigarettes some of
you may know the story in the early
1990s r.j. Reynolds wanted to introduce
a cigarette targeting african-americans
uptown cigarettes urban youthful hip
cool unfortunately I'll talk about more
in this in a few minutes for
unfortunately for RJ Reynolds a group of
activists in Philadelphia where was
going to be test marketed civil rights
activists health professionals church
groups and community groups got together
and said no not in our community and
they were successful by skillful use of
the media to prevent r.j. Reynolds from
releasing this product are you bipolar
dramatic increase recently in in
direct-to-consumer advertising and
prescription drugs documented studies
showing that direct-to-consumer
advertising increases the number of
people who ask their doctors about a
drug and increases the number of doctors
prescribing that drug whether or not
they believe it's truly indicated those
are examples of marketing having an
impact on health and there's a
substantial body of research evidence
that in fact advertising works not
simply to shift market share as industry
contends but to recruit new users and
particularly to recruit new users for
the most profitable markets children and
young people both because they're none
they're not users
and because they have the potential of
being lifetime customers at least as
long as they live the third practice is
retail distribution this is how
companies get their products out to
consumers and so the prices they chop
the availability of products how easy it
is to get access to them influences for
unhealthy products and for healthy
products so for example there's are a
number of research studies showing that
the more guns are available the higher
the rates of firearm injury and
homicides and there have been a number
of lawsuits and legislative proposals
designed to put more responsibility in
the gun industry for the retail
distribution of its products the number
of studies now the show that wealthier
communities are more likely to have
supermarkets with better access to fresh
fruits and vegetables and low-income
communities of a higher density of fast
food and other unhealthy food outlets
and good research evidence showing that
the density of alcohol outlets is
associated with increased drinking and
drinking problems and finally pricing
the decisions that companies made about
how much to charge and who to charge it
to influences health through a number of
pathways and what what economists call
price elasticity how much demand
influenced by price is particularly
important for vulnerable populations
young people people of color low-income
populations for Alcohol Tobacco and so
on on the other side charging too much
can deny access to health enhancing
products to people who need them and
some of the debates about drug prices
particularly AIDS medications both here
in the United States and in the
developing world illustrate that so the
there's a substantial body of research
evidence which my colleagues and I
recently have been publishing about to
synthesize and summarize that literature
demonstrating that
companies do and don't do has a
substantial influence on health these
are the 10 tobacco executives testifying
before Congress to tell the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
and they testify that nicotine was not
addictive and just a few years later it
was revealed that in their files were
documents which has been there for 20
years showing that in fact they knew
full well these guys by the way within
two years were all out of their job not
because they lied to Congress but
because there the bottom line was hurt
by the bad publicity about lying to
Congress yes we don't need to worry
about their future the second point I
wanted to make is that the influence of
corporations on health is growing the
proportion of the gross domestic product
devoted to advertising has doubled in
the last two decades we've seen
advertising in the back of our taxi cabs
on buses in schools in public places
Kaiser Family Health Foundation recently
did a study of television advertising to
children the most advertised products
are foods eighty to ninety percent of
the television food advertising is for
unhealthy products hi Saul high-fat
high-sugar products they calculated the
number of hours that children from the
ages of two to a team are exposed to
food advertising for unhealthy food and
I took those numbers and determined that
the average American child spends more
time watching advertisements for
unhealthy food than he or she does in a
college classroom getting a bachelor's
degree that says something about the
exposure to unhealthy messages that we
expose people to people also eat more
because of macroeconomic trends people
eat more food out of the house and and
turn to more of their needs into the
market economy advertisers also appeal
to
all of our baser instincts in order to
sell their products this is an
advertisement for a malt liquor another
example of a product that uses a lot of
racial targeting and their advertising
towards african-americans as well as
towards youth this says colt 45
introduces the adult game for Game
adults and the implication is if you
drink colt 45 you'll have someone to
play with wearing a bikini and your life
will be very different and at the same
time as we've seen the increased
penetration of all sectors of our life
by corporations those countervailing
forces family community church
neighborhood organizations have also
declined an influence so they've really
filled a vacuum giving them a very
powerful influence on health and disease
and this is particularly true in cities
which increasingly are becoming
concentrated places for selling you know
this shopping mall is one familiar
example and increasingly the form of
cities is designed not by what would
make cities healthy not but what would
mention cities good places to live or
visit but by what will increase
opportunities for selling the Third
Point and very relevant to the
conference here today and tomorrow is
that corporate practices maintain and
exacerbate inequities in health and for
people who are interested in reading
more about this my colleagues and I have
just published in the latest issue of
the journal of health care for the poor
and underserved the role of the tobacco
alcohol and food industry in cancer and
the potential for changing corporate
practices as a way of primary prevention
of cancer and cancer disparities a
substantial body of literature targets
both that companies target their
advertising to disadvantaged groups
young people within African Americans
Latinos Asians and that this targeted
marketing has an impact
a second way of targeting that we talked
about already is that healthy products
tend to be more available in better off
and white communities and unhealthy
products more available in low-income
and communities of color we talked about
uptown being designed specifically to
appeal to a group already with poor
health status and a variety of
strategies of pricing strategies selling
loose e-cigarettes Saturday night
specials make those products especially
attractive and accessible to low-income
communities malt liquor is far cheaper
per ounce of high than wine or other
forms of spirits heavily marketed in
low-income in african-american
communities so based on all this we've
come up my colleagues and I with
something we call disease promotion
individual or organizational activities
that encourage unhealthy lifestyles or
behaviors and contribute to unhealthy
environments and when corporations do
that we call a corporate health
corporate disease promotion and I think
the question that we need to ask both is
health professionals and as a society
what's the appropriate tolerance for
disease promotion in a society and
currently we spend far far more as a
society on disease promotion than we do
in health promotion and so our capacity
as health professionals to promote
health is much compromised and if we're
going to change that we need to get to
that root issue that I talked about
about the relationship between Marcus
and government
and at the policy level I think we need
to ask for what would be the policy
agenda that would that would discourage
disease promotion particularly corporate
disease promotion and what would be
those that would better enable
government to protect particularly
vulnerable populations and something I
live in Washington Heights and you know
walk down the streets and see the
alcohol and tobacco ads and I think what
would it take to transform our
communities so that health was the
default option what would it take to be
able to have the the messages there are
communities were given the product
available the product availability that
would be easier to choose health and
disease and that transformation is our
agenda right that's what we need to be
thinking about both in the community
level and at the policy level the fourth
point I wanted to make is that we can do
something about this I mentioned the
Uptown campaign increasingly I think
local and state health departments are
beginning to see that they too can take
on special interests that are promoting
disease at the expense of health and I
think increasingly we're seeing that
action at the local and state level
because the federal government has
abdicated its responsibility in this
area and so we're seeing the
laboratories of municipal and state
governments developing new approaches in
New York City the ban on trans fat and
the newly passed requirements for fast
food establishments to post calorie the
many city governments looking to better
regulate the retail distribution of guns
parents groups around the country are
mobilizing to get to end what are called
pouring right contracts the right of
coke or pepsi or other companies to sell
their products exclusively in public
schools
in Seattle such a group successfully ban
cove forced the Seattle School Board to
end its exclusive contract with code and
in many schools they're trying to get
commercial food entirely out of the
school system that at least schools
should be a safe zone where kids can
find healthy food and and the school
districts that have approached this with
innovation creativity have found that it
is possible to not lose money and to
create a school Food Program that kids
like and that is health promoting
instead of unhealthy I want to briefly
describe several strategies that public
health folks have developed to reduce
the harm from corporate practices the
first is contesting information many of
you have probably heard about the truth
campaign campaign sponsored by the
American Legacy Foundation funded by the
master settlement agreement that tried
to show young people that in choosing to
smoke they were being manipulated by the
tobacco industry to do something that
there was against their interests not to
say smoking is for adults only so don't
do it what better message could you even
to go out and try it but instead to say
don't be a sucker and this super-sized
Ronald McDonald you know having people
rethink who is this character and what
it really is characteristics the this is
a alcopops do you know what alcopops are
sweetened alcoholic beverages what one
advocate called training wheels for
drinkers meant for people who don't yet
have a taste for alcohol but with a high
sugar content make them appealing and
the center for science in the public
interest put this a tad not trying to
convince kids not to drink because of
the alcohol but showing its connection
to weight gain and the national
association of african american tobacco
control programs put out the other end
to use ethnic and racial
appeals in the reverse way that the
tobacco industry does a little more edgy
changing happy meals to a different way
of having people think about what's
inside that McDonald's and I think we've
seen a dramatic change in public
attitudes around SUVs in the last four
or five years not only because of the
increase in the price of gasoline but
also because of the environmental
foreign policy global warming and other
concerns and just to show you something
from the other side this is a group that
objects to government playing a role in
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms regulation
and said this should be the name of a
convenience store not a government
agency another way for reducing the harm
is to regulate you know regulation has
gotten a bad name but we created a
regulatory apparatus in the first part
of the 20th century you know the Food
and Drug Administration in 1906 after
the expos of Upton Sinclair's voc the
jungle showing the horrific practices in
the meat industry well we saw very
similar practices just a few weeks ago
in Iowa exposed you know not by a public
health crusader but by the American
Humane Association concerned about
animal rights and the what can be
regulated as prosaic as you know what
goes into a vending machine to as lofty
as one of the trade rules and to what
extent should our trade treaties around
tobacco and alcohol reflect health
concerns as well as business concerns
and the Framework Convention for tobacco
control approved a few years ago by many
nations including finally one of the
last the United States does provide a
model for addressing global trade and
having a counterweight to global
corporations in thinking about health
and I think finally we need to reassert
government's obligation and will to
protect public health that I think
there's always in American history
you've always been debates about what's
the appropriate role for the
market and what's the appropriate role
for government and in the last decade or
two we've seen the balance tilled very
heavily towards the market and I think
if we're going to you know the one
statistic that alarms me you know as a
as a parent is a study that was about a
year ago in the New England Journal of
Medicine saying that if present trends
and obesity and diabetes continue
children and grandchildren will have
shorter lifespans and we do a five to
seven years you know what does that say
about our society that after a hundred
years of increasing lifespan that what
we are going to turn over to our
children is a society where their
lifespan is shortening and and so it's
to think about what can I do to be
assured that my son and my grandchildren
won't inherit that legacy and so I want
to suggest to you four or five points of
what I think could be a policy agenda to
begin to reverse that very broad stroke
and I'm going to end with that and I'd
like if we have a little time to hear
some of your thoughts and reactions to
that so the first suggestion is that we
create a legal framework that provides
consumers with a right to know the
health consequences of all legal
products and with companies a duty to
disclose the information they have
second that we establish as national
policy to protect children and other
vulnerable populations against targeted
marketing that promotes unhealthy
behaviors or lifestyles and the business
objection to that is well that's a
violation of free speech although the
extension of the First Amendment to
commercial speech is a relatively recent
phenomenon just in the latter part of
the 20th century so the founding fathers
hadn't considered that issue and England
to show that other advanced free market
societies recently decided to ban all
food advertising to children under 12 so
we have some choices there the third
part of the proposal has to do with as
long as corporations and their
supporters
have special access to government they
will be able to use the political arena
to get what is good for them and not
what's good for the population as a
whole and that is through lobbying
through campaign contributions through
you know the revolving door between
government and industry through voting
rights through giving personhood to
corporations and many times we Public
Health think those are political issues
that don't have anything to do with us
and I feel very differently I think that
if we're going to succeed in advancing a
public health agenda in reducing
disparities in health which we say is a
national agenda then we're going to need
to look at what are the rules in the
political arena by which we make
decisions the next is to really
dramatically increase sanctions for
deliberate distortions of science and
withholding information designed to
protect corporate interests we've seen
several recent examples of that with the
drug industry we've certainly seen it
with tobacco industry my guess is in the
coming years as we get into the files of
the food industry we'll see similarly
with them that their understanding of
the consequences of some of the products
they've been using they they decided to
put their interests ahead of the
interest of population health so I think
that's a public policy issue and finally
and this is particularly for those of us
working in academic settings whether as
faculty or staff or students we need to
be sure that our that we are educated
about having the skills and competencies
we need to address this issue in the
public health and in the political arena
to be able to reduce the harm from
corporate practices thank you very much
that was absolutely fantastic and just
too to connect what you presented with
us to some events earlier let me just
make a brief comment that I have a
question ok I'll I i am just enthralled
with the concept of corporate disease
ocean i I cannot say just how great a
contribution that concept makes in
addition I in terms of some of the
advocacy work that follows from what
your suggestion suggesting here it's
noteworthy that in the morning session
dr. Greer who's professor here talked
about in the movement to get services in
schools for autistic children and other
children services and parents were key
and that the advocacy of parents was
effective in getting school board so in
other words he's you know sitting on a
couple decades of research for
everything that's been done in the
schools and all the research basically
came from the funding that school boards
were forced to to make available to meet
the needs of children because of parents
who advocated in a session that I did
part of what I put out was a call for a
21st century global movement for equity
in health for all and so would i now see
and triple was talked about was the need
for us all here to engage in social
action for social justice so when you
talk about the kind of training that
needs to go on the question I have in
mind is well it does become a kind of
movement a social justice movement if it
does require social action for social
justice it does require advocacy of
various types or the government or
corporations how do we create that
consciousness because actually I
about to have a consciousness that what
affects one affects all but how you know
how do we you know i'm looking at
graduate students are so overburdened
with the concept of finishing and
dissertation and typically take me here
to recover you know what are those
skills how do we part the skills and
also the values that will allow you to
fill your vision that is fantastic that
we put the personal corporations and
governments to stop corporate disease
promotion well great question things up
and i think their answers at a few
different levels the first thing I think
is to acknowledge and recognize that the
building blocks of that social movement
are already there there there in the
tobacco control movement and
particularly the parts that are now
realizing that we can separate our local
and our local efforts and global efforts
one of the totally alarming consequences
of our successes in tobacco control in
the United States in the last two
decades has been that we've driven them
to Asia Africa and Latin America where
the rates of smoking or increasing I
think the tobacco control convention and
the advocacy around that provide an
excellent model that we have an
obligation and responsibility will also
be more successful at both levels if we
can link that together I think the food
movement the food justice movement are
another example of a movement and I do
I'm doing a lot of work around food now
in communities in New York is astonished
by the degree to which neighborhood
organizations parents food grooves are
willing to mobilize around this slower
to take on the food industry but it's an
issue in which a lot of people are
already in motion I think there's
similar action among senior citizens
around the drug industry among the AIDS
community around drugs so I think one of
the things is to be in how do we leave
those movements together our website
which the address is there is our first
very modest attempt to do so and we
certainly hope you look at it invite you
to write forward if you're interested
and
and we really need to create meeting
places where people can come in an
exchange lessons on the curriculum side
I think there are a few things first we
need to teach advocacy you know that's
as much a part of our curriculum as
teaching how to do program
implementation and program planning
advocacy both the community level India
and policy level the political system
level and I also think that we need to
develop a body of knowledge around
corporate practices and how they affect
health and how they change them we've
made some first efforts at developing
courses in that area there's a course
outline on the website that shows and we
really welcome suggestions from others
and you know contributions about how
best to do that not a question a little
bit more on the concept of disease
promotion in the cultural context I live
in a County up stay out of Orange County
is safe to say that most of my County
does not look like me so that there are
certain things that I made you more into
it in soon so for example it is SUV
country and every time I get stuck in my
Honda one of my name is an SUV comes and
pulls me out of marketing why I need to
purchase an SUV I will not because of
gas prices i will not because i just
think that ugly
and what they just in the environment
but every time I get stuff out to the
pool one of my SUV neighbors so I just
wanted you to speak a little bit more
about the concept of disease promotion
and culturally how it appears to
different people Wow good question of I
think advertisers are very smart and I
think we could learn a lot from them I
think they look to root the appeals of
their products in very specific groups
you know by gender socioeconomic status
race ethnicity language this is a slight
digression but I think it's relevant I'm
working with a colleague and have two
colleagues and epidemiologist and
anthropologists looking at how the
manufacturers of psychiatric drugs are
targeted Hispanic populations and I
think it requires doing what the what
industry does which is really analyzing
their appeals and understanding how they
reach people and then we need to be both
to contest that we need to do it in
culturally relevant terms and I think
that work is just beginning I think it's
the starting point of developing
effective interventions to change it of
understanding you know how do young
people have how do they read these malt
liquor ads and also what would be the
images that would change how they read
them I think it's a very important and
promising area of work thank you for
your talk what should I sort of see is
that when we're doing official markings
or things people like to do in this
instant gratification as part of it such
by by the new SUV we need to have it
it's pretty nice whereas some of these
health outcomes are longer term they
don't see an immediate impact ladies so
you stop smoking you don't see it for 20
years down the line when you don't had
one cancel out my sword whole thing is
here how do we get people to buy into
that initial thing that doing the right
thing or the healthy thing is better for
them rather than the unhealthy I guess
I've thoughts in two different
directions one is obviously as in all
areas of public health prevention is
better than you know primary prevention
is better than secondary prevention and
people aren't born wanting to be smokers
heavy drinkers and so on it happens in
an environment and you know as Kelly
Brownell psychologist who's looks at
food at Yale talks about an obesogenic
environment and if there are people you
know growing up in Anna be sick genic
environment they're more likely to be
overweight or the proportion is more
likely to be overweight to the first
stretch steps which are policy steps are
to change those environments and that's
slow work it's not going to happen
overnight I think the second thing is
the more individual level appeal and I
think some of the the last two
presentations spoke to some of the
issues of that of helping people to stop
doing things that are bad for them I
think we really need to help support
people and we under need to understand
the social context in which people are
smoking and drinking and having unsafe
sex and even some parts of that have to
do with the ways that corporations are
advertising and appealing to our
insecurities and stressing us out and so
on and then I think the the secondary
prevention there are a set of
technologies that we have developed over
the years ago well you know beyond the
particular void corporations do and
don't do that help people there's one
other thought i had about you know
trying to the word have been doing
around food what i found is that
people find it easy to make healthy food
more available you know through farmers
market it's the new green card proposal
that New York City did through putting
healthy foods in bodegas on York City
Health Department initiative improving
school lunches there's a lot of support
for that and that's important work but I
think if that's all we do we're not
going to successfully reverse the
obesity epidemic because the other thing
we need to do is stop the promotion of
unhealthy food and that's much tougher
for two reasons one reason is it
requires taking on the food industry and
all their political muscle and the other
reason is it means telling people you
know don't drink that extra code don't
you know don't eat that Twinkie and I
think if we didn't have that din of the
industry egging people on to keep doing
what's bad for them our work would be
much easier so I think that's the
support for taking this on in the policy
arena as well as healthy individuals I
don't know that speaks directly to your
question I just have to ask you just one
question
you mentioned something about the
corporate muscle the idea I mean we had
we had been here with the psychological
association few weeks till we're talking
about a lot of people's grant money and
presidential campaigns and all these
other kinds of things are contingent on
getting money from the people who
benefit from this corporate health
disease promotion kind of initiative I
mean it seems like we do something about
that all something how do i get my grand
how do I get my chain around I could
cover target all these things because
somebody getting some of the money from
people were beautifully from this
corporate muscle used to come absolutely
and I think you know another example of
corporate credit penetration is at the
university research community and that
Berkeley recently accepted you know a
big chunk of money from the tobacco
industry to look at ways to discourage
you from smoking and many of the Yemenis
of smoking advocate said in the
University of California system were
appalled that Berkeley would be able to
do that and the principal investigator
of that study said I'm looking for ways
to help kids stop smoking what could be
bad about that but you're the I think we
need to just take half a step back and
say why is this backhoe industry doing
that they want to buy credibility that's
their strategy and if we aren't smart
enough to ask those questions you know
i'm not sure we deserve to be entrusted
with protecting the public health and
some of these your tough questions I
don't want to simplify them but I think
unless we ask those ethical questions in
our universities and our professional
associations you know we risk losing our
credibility it's not just a personal
morality it's losing our credibility to
engage the public of these issues and
that's I'm glad you brought that up
because I think it's a very important
issue yes and in addition to that they
seek the money and the tobacco companies
basically in charge of their research so
whatever the findings are the tobacco
industry
open tuesday with a shoes to allow the
researchers to report so that's it was
another life vicious cycle I remember
reading a piece about I think it was
gambia America was trying to give them
GM corn and so they did some research
they weren't sure they didn't want to do
with European nations mind doing it so
they decided they didn't want to take it
and colin powell said to them well it's
good enough for Americans that is good
enough for you and what shocked me about
that is that i didn't know i was eating
Jam corn and so like these are things i
kind of like dishearten me genetically
modified oh sorry and these are things I
dishearten me because these are my
things that happen in low-income
communities and you know all of these on
advertisements but look what's going on
like the bigger picture and that goes
back to equity like everybody needs to
understand that you know we're all
victims here and I just sometimes I just
feel so overwhelmed in this heart and I
don't even know where to begin to start
addressing these issues on a level where
people can see that it's all of us it's
not just them or is not just us it's all
of us and I know that once that does
happen whether it's some equity then
real change will occur but I just don't
know where to start ah I will they say
one thing that might be at that counter
point is the place to end unless someone
else wants to say something I fully
understand and I certainly wake up days
and wondering the worth of of all this
but I think on the other hand you know
one step at a time one day at a time
that if you look at the advances in this
country in the last century in terms of
any area to civil rights education they
came about as a result of people
mobilizing you know asserting their
rights organizing and winning then
someone who you know came up in a
student and anti-war movement of the 60s
the environmental movement I've seen in
my own lifetime you know those dramatic
transformations when one day it looked
like nothing could change and the next
day you know thousands of people tens of
thousands of people hundreds of
thousands of people were thinking and
acting differently so I would encourage
you and I know you know if you were
talking five minutes from now you could
say it is to find that one thing that
does move you and start working on it
and that's what will make a difference
and together we can all do it that was
fantastic and it stated for a second
because one of the things one of the
first things that many of the people
this room need to move on is their
dissertation and here it's a very
expensive endeavor and so I wonder you
could I'd like to not have so many
students the next decade go into dead at
the tune of 102 in two thousand dollars
so it should get an advertisement for
your alternative dr. Emoto probably
thank you sure in fall 2007 city
university opened its doctor of Public
Health Program we our focus is on urban
health on the health of populations and
cities and we're particularly interested
as you may guess on the connections
between public health and social justice
the our first track which we opened with
14 students in September is in what we
call community health and society it
includes health education and behavioral
sciences and you know what our uptown
neighbors called socio medical sciences
our second track in epidemiology is
opening in the fall of two thousand
eight attracted environmental and
occupational health of 2009 and in
health policy and management in 2010
this is all part of a plan of the City
University of New York to open a new
school of public health in 2010 that
will bring together our existing public
health programs at Hunter where
bass brooklyn college lehman college and
graduate center where our doctoral
program is based and i have with me a
few flyers for doctoral program and if
you were interested I'd be happy to give
them to you if you go to the Graduate
Center website which is WWE CEO a.e edu
and I'm do programs click on public
health you'll find a description of the
program would love to see some of you
with applicants
you
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu